Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 41. Nach langer, langer Zeit geht es hier wieder weiter im Programm. Die Pause hatte viele Gründe, die ich hier gar nicht weiter auslegen möchte. Viel wichtiger ist das Thema heute, denn heute geht es um Sprachen und für die Sprachen habe ich wieder mal einen kompetenten Gast eingeladen. Der Gast heißt Maha und den stelle ich euch auch gleich vor nach der Musik. Ja, hier sind auch die Worte im Hintergrund zu hören. Ich sag jetzt erstmal Maha, Mikrofon auf. Hallo. Hallo, guten Tag. Tja, wir hatten schon ein paar Worte hier ganz am Anfang. Füms, bevetet, seuuu. Was ist das?
Die Urlaute, naja gut, also das sind wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich die Urlaute. Also man weiß schon so ein bisschen, was die Urlaute geklungen haben könnten. Und man weiß, dass wahrscheinlich mindestens ein A sehr alt ist. Man weiß aber auch, dass vordere, gerundete Vokale, also was wie Ü oder Ä eher selten sind in den Sprachen. Also die qualifizieren sich nicht gut als Urlaute, aber die sind nun gerade da drin.
Ja, da sollten wir vielleicht mal kurz aufklären, was das war. Also das, was wir gehört haben, war die Ursonate von Kurt Schwitters. Kurt Schwitters ist ein alter Künstler aus Hannover, der in den 30er Jahren vor allem sehr aktiv war, sehr wegweisend in vielerlei Hinsicht. Also nicht nur mit solchen Performanzen, sondern auch als Typograf wegweisend und Mitbegründer dieser dadaistischen Bewegung. Großartige Gedichte gemacht wie Anna Blume, bis von hinten wie von vorn. Auf jeden Fall also ein Wortkünstler. Und von daher ganz angemessene Einleitung für unser Thema heute. Denn das Thema ist Sprache und ja, ich habe dich eingeladen, Maha, weil du ja zumindest auf dem Papier bisher erst mal kompetent bist. Was machst du? Kannst du das mal kurz erzählen?
Ja, ich bin Linguist oder auch Sprachwissenschaftler und ich beschäftige mich also beruflich und den ganzen Tag mit Sprachen und Sprache. Allerdings nicht so sehr mit dem Deutschen. Also viele glauben immer, Sprachwissenschaftler müssten sich in Deutschland zwangsläufig mit dem Deutschen beschäftigen. Das habe ich eigentlich nie getan. Ich habe auch nicht Germanistik studiert, sondern allgemeine Sprachwissenschaft und Romanistik. Und bin jetzt auch vor allen Dingen befasst mit romanischen Sprachen, also vor allen Dingen mit Italienisch, italienischen Dialekten, Französisch, Spanisch, Katalanisch, also romanischen Sprachen eben. Aber ich habe auch sehr viel über Baskisch gemacht und mache das auch immer noch. Also Baskisch ist jetzt keine romanische Sprache, aber die steht halt in engem Kontakt mit den romanischen Sprachen. Das Besondere am Baskischen ist aber, dass das ganz anders ist. Also in Europa eine völlig exotische Sprache. Und das hat mich halt fasziniert. Und da habe ich mich dann mal so ein bisschen reingefuchst in das Baskische. Also nicht nur so ein bisschen. Meine Dissertation auch über romanische Einflüsse im Baskischen geschrieben und habe auch Baskisch richtig gelernt, was tatsächlich nicht so ganz einfach ist.
Wie viele Sprachen sprichst du?
Das kann ich nicht sagen. Ich kann immer nur sagen, wie viele ich ungefähr gelernt habe. Also richtig reingekniet habe ich mich in ungefähr zwölf Sprachen. Ich habe auch noch mal ein paar mehr so reingeschnuppert. Das zählt dann nicht richtig. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass man, wenn man Sprachen nicht dauernd praktiziert, man auch sehr viel wieder verlernt. Also ich habe mal eine ganze lange Zeit auch russisch gelernt, aber ich habe es dann nicht mehr praktiziert. Und jetzt, gut, ich kann da noch was lesen, aber sprechen auf Russisch geht einfach nicht mehr. Und ich habe mich auch mal eine längere Zeit mit Japanisch beschäftigt und das kann ich auch nicht richtig sprechen. Also das ist einfach, da muss man sie richtig dann auch immer reinknien und das ständig praktizieren. Und das geht halt nicht mit beliebig vielen Sprachen. Gut, das ging ja schon, aber dann macht man gar nichts anderes mehr.
Und Japanisch ist ja auch nur wirklich eine Riesenausnahme, oder?
Also Japanisch ist auch eine sogenannte isolierte Sprache, wo man keine Verwandtschaftsbeziehungen mit anderen Sprachen hat. Das gleiche gilt auch für Baskisch, das ist auch eine isolierte Sprache. Und solche Sprachen fallen natürlich immer auf, weil sie irgendwie ganz anders sind, als das, was man sonst so kennt.
Was gibt es da noch? Also im Ruf, isoliert zu sein, steht auch immer das Ungarische?
Ne, das ist nicht isoliert. Das gehört zur finn-ugrischen Sprachfamilie. Also zusammen mit dem finnischen, dem estnischen und noch einer ganzen Reihe anderer kleinerer Sprachen aus dem Oral. Und die sind halt doch sehr eng miteinander verwandt und bilden also eine Sprachfamilie. Und man glaubt sogar, dass es da noch weitere Verbindungen gibt zu einer größeren Gruppe, die man dann Uralo-Altaisch nennt. Also da könnte zum Beispiel entfernt verwandt das türkische und die anderen Turksprachen auch sein. Also das ist wirklich nicht isoliert.
Aber was heißt denn dann verwandt? Weil der gemeine Ungar versteht ja natürlich dann nix vom türkischen. Und ich war auch mal in Ungarn, ich hab das Thema natürlich auch angesprochen. Und man meinte so, ja, wir sind halt irgendwie alleine. Und irgendjemand hat mal gesagt, das Finnische sei dem vielleicht ja auch ähnlich. Ich glaube, dann hängt es mal so ein bisschen ab, was der Sprachenwissenschaftler des Tages so von sich gibt.
Ja, nee, nee, also das mit dem Türkischen, das ist halt eine sehr entfernte Verwandtschaft, wo man auch nicht so genau weiß, wie das ist. Aber mit dem Finnischen und dem Ästlichen gibt es wirklich ganz deutlich Übereinstimmung. Also von Sprachverwandtschaften spricht man immer dann, wenn es Übereinstimmungen gibt im Wortschatz, also wenn man irgendwie gleiche Wörter findet. Aber es muss eben auch Übereinstimmungen in der Grammatik geben. Und das gibt es eben auch bei Finnisch und Ungarisch. Natürlich sind die Übereinstimmungen nicht so groß, dass sie sich jetzt verständigen könnten. Und das Gefühl ist auch nicht da, dass man irgendwie sehr eng verwandte Sprachen spricht. So ein Gefühl vielleicht, wie wir haben mit Niederländisch und Deutsch, wo man noch denkt, das hat viel miteinander zu tun. Aber es sind auf jeden Fall solche systematischen Beziehungen da. Und deshalb muss man da auch von Sprachverwandtschaft sprechen.
Wie gut erforscht ist so die europäische Sprachenwelt? Gibt es da noch große weiße Löcher auf der Landkarte, wo keiner so richtig weiß, was er davon halten soll, wie sich das entwickelt hat?
Ja, da gibt es schon große Löcher, auch in Europa. Also es ist einmal so, ich nannte schon das Baskische. Das Baskische ist immer noch nicht richtig gut erforscht. Also da weiß man relativ wenig drüber. Da könnte man noch viel mehr zutage fördern, vor allen Dingen, wenn man da auch mal historisch erforscht. Da gibt es jetzt nicht so viel Material, was weit in die Vergangenheit zurückreicht. Aber das ist eigentlich noch nicht gemacht worden. Da gibt es schon noch Möglichkeiten. Und dann gibt es natürlich viele Kleinsprachen in Europa, über die man ganz, ganz wenig weiß. Also zum Beispiel aus dem Bereich der Turksprachen in der Ukraine bzw. in Moldawien gibt es das Gagauzische. Da weiß man ganz wenig drüber. Und auf dem Balkan gibt es viele Sprachen, die man ganz schlecht erforscht. Und dann ist ja immer die Sache, was ist eine Sprache? Was ist ein Dialekt? Es gibt natürlich viele Variitäten von Sprachen. Zum Beispiel in Italien kann man das sehr schön sehen. Da glaubt man so, wenn man von außen kommt, auch die sprechen alle Italienisch. Das tun sie aber eigentlich gar nicht. Und all diese Variitäten in Italien sind auch ganz, ganz schlecht erforscht.
Was sprechen die denn sonst?
Die sprechen halt ihren lokalen Dialekt am Ort. Also da gibt es halt eine ganze Menge. Das variiert halt. Ich selber hab ein bisschen gearbeitet bei so genannten Apenninen-Umbrich. Die Bezeichnung ist auch von mir, obwohl sie inzwischen auch von anderen angenommen worden ist. Das ist also das Dialektgebiet im umbrischen Apenninen-Raum, also mitten in Italien, in den Bergen dort. Und das ist wirklich schon sehr sonderbar. Also man erkennt, das ist aus dem Lateinischen entstanden, das ist romanisch, aber mit dem Italienischen hat das sehr wenig zu tun. Und die Leute können sich auch dann, also na gut, natürlich können die alle auch Italienisch, aber wenn man als Außenstehender dahin kommt und kann sehr gut Italienisch, versteht man erst mal gar nichts. Und das wird sogar noch intensiver, wenn man in die Abruzzen reingeht, weil sich da die grammatischen Abweichungen noch viel stärker zeigen. Und das ist dann wirklich ganz anders und praktisch nicht erforscht. Da gibt es dann so ein, zwei Aufsätze. Da hat einer mal festgestellt, dass im Aprozessischen eben auch die Substantive konjugiert werden. Das heißt, sie kriegen so Endungen wie die Verben. Das fanden dann die Wissenschaftlergemeinde ganz toll. Da sind dann mal zwei Leute hingefahren und dann gibt es noch zwei, drei weitere Aufsätze darüber. Aber wie das nun genau funktioniert, weiß man bis heute nicht. Also da gibt es wirklich auch mitten in Europa noch wirklich viel zu forschen. Nee, natürlich nicht. Da gibt es natürlich schon ein gewisses Interesse. Das Interesse haben meistens die Leute am Ort. Aber es fehlt dann das Geld von irgendwelchen großen Forschungsinstitutionen, um jede sprachliche Besonderheit zu erforschen.
Gut, Forschungsinteresse wird ja immer meistens dort gemacht, wo es auch Geld zu verdienen gibt. Genau. Gibt es da irgendeinen wirtschaftlichen Anreiz, Sprachen zu erforschen? Wenn ich so als Baskische denke, dann fällt mir als erstes ein bisschen der Aspekt der Völkerverständigung ein, weil Wastenland ist ja nun mal ein ziemlich wilder Ort, was die politische Situation und den Widerstand und dieses Unabhängigkeitsgefühl betrifft. Es ist ja auch nicht der einzige Ort in Spanien. Es gibt ja auch noch Katalonien, wobei das Katalonische ist, aber dann schon dem Spanischen deutlich ähnlicher. Das ist auch eine romantische Sprache. Ja, es ist eine französisch-spanische Mixtur. Aber das Baskische ist halt komplett separat. Da kann man natürlich schon verstehen, dass die sich nicht so ohne Weiteres eingemeinden wollen. Von daher hat das natürlich dann auch für Identität eine große Wichtigkeit. Vielleicht gehen wir da noch mal hin, weil ich wollte jetzt eigentlich eh noch mal so ein bisschen hinterfragen, wo kommt die Sprache her? Also was weiß man darüber, wie der Mensch sich seine Sprache angeeignet und entwickelt hat? Und was kann man dann auch aus der aktuellen Sprachenforschung daraus ablesen? Vielleicht noch mal so mit dem Beispiel der Basken dann auch noch mal hinterher, die ja sich nun, ja, was weiß ich, wo die herkommen. Vielleicht sind die ja außerirdische.
Nein, nein, nein. Die sind irgendwann nach Europa eingewandert, und zwar vor den Indogermanen. Das ist ziemlich deutlich. Dann sind die Indogermanen halt über Europa hinweggegangen und haben alle vorher dort vorhandenen Sprachen, da wurde natürlich vorher, da gab es vorher Menschen, also es ist auch klar, dass da vorher gesprochen wurde. Die sind aber alle verschwunden, diese Sprachen. Und es ist eigentlich nur das Indogermanische zunächst mal übrig geblieben. Nur die Basken, die sind eben da, wo sie auch heute noch sind, einfach geblieben. Das liegt an bestimmten, ja, man kann sagen, geophysischen oder geografischen Umständen, dass sie sich da halten konnten. Da gibt es Berge. Und es gibt da den Golf von Biskaya, der eine sehr gute Verkehrsmöglichkeit ist. Das heißt also, wer von Aquitanien, also von Frankreich, nach Spanien wollte, konnte immer sehr leicht über das Meer an der Stelle.
Ach so, man musste da nicht durch.
Man musste nicht durch die Berge, die an der Stelle wirklich nicht so bequem sind. Und da sind dann auch wenig Leute durchgekommen. Und aus dem Grunde konnte sich das Barsgeschirr da gut halten. Das war einfach ein geografischer, man möchte fast sagen Zufall, der dazu geführt hat, dass die da lange Zeit nicht bedroht war. Also alle Eroberer hatten immer großes Interesse daran, wo kamen die dann her, die Indogermanen?
Wo ist der Möhrenkuchen?
Die Indogermanen, ja, es ist noch nicht so ganz klar, wo die herkommen. Also da gibt es verschiedene Hypothesen. Also irgendwie, ich denke, das Klausibelste ist, dass die so aus Vorderasien kommen.
Und das stellt jetzt sozusagen die Sprachmehrheit im europäischen Raum.
Das ist jetzt die europäische Sprachmehrheit. Dann sind auch andere Leute eingewandert. Wir hatten vorhin schon die finnugrischen Völker genannt. Die sind also später dann nach Europa gekommen. Und die haben natürlich dann auch wieder...
Die hatten wir schon erwähnt?
Ja, bei den Ungarn.
Ach so, die Ungarn.
Also es sind dann auch andere als die Indogermanen nach Europa eingewandert.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Also es sind natürlich alle nach Europa irgendwann eingewandert. Zuerst natürlich die Basken, dann die Indogermanen und dann...
Und gibt es irgendwelche Erkenntnisse, wo diese Basken herkommen?
Nee, aber gut.
Außerirdische, ich sag's dir.
Außerirdische, ganz erheblich. Man nimmt natürlich an, dass die Einwanderung nach Europa letztlich, also ganz am Anfang irgendwie aus Afrika kommt. Aber genau das weiß man da auch nicht. Aber man denkt eben, dass der Mensch und die Sprachen aus Afrika kommen.
Okay, gut. Die Sprachen kommen aus Afrika, das heißt, da müssen sie ja dann auch erst mal entwickelt haben. Und wie wir ja von Kurt Schwitters gehört haben, am Anfang war alles noch so FIMS, Bibliothek, CU. Wie kam denn der Mensch dazu, so eine komplexe Sprachenwelt überhaupt zu entwickeln?
Ja, da kann man auch ein paar vorsichtige Aussagen machen, muss man aber trotzdem immer sehr vorsichtig sein, weil wir da nicht so viele Sachen, Informationen haben. Also man geht davon aus, dass sich, wenn sich also irgendwelche Primaten, sagen wir mal, sozial organisieren, sie auch kommunizieren müssen. Sonst klappt das mit der komplexen sozialen Organisation. Das haben wir auch sonst im Tierreich. Immer wenn es eine gewisse soziale Organisation gibt, muss auch eine Kommunikation stattfinden. Wenn die soziale Organisation einfach ist, wie bei den Bienen zum Beispiel, dann ist auch die Kommunikationsform einfach. Die machen da so Schwänzeltänze und können damit angeben, wo sie Futterlagen gibt. Das reicht dann auch schon, denn die sozialen Rollen sind da alle schon vorher festgelegt. Da muss man also nicht viel aushandeln. Das sieht dann bei den Primaten anders aus. Also wenn die Primaten da von den Bäumen runterkommen und in die Savanne gehen, dann müssen sie, um zu überleben, wirklich eine soziale Gemeinschaft bilden. Und da muss ausgehandelt werden, wer da der Chef ist und wer da welche Rolle übernimmt. Und da muss man kommunizieren. Also in dem Moment geht es also irgendwie los mit sprachlicher Kommunikation. Und die menschliche Gesellschaft ist dann eben weiter fortgeschritten in diesem Problem der sozialen Organisation. Man hat deshalb eben natürlich auch noch komplexere Kommunikationssysteme, als das bei den übrigen Primaten eventuell der Fall ist. Okay.
Und gibt es dann, wie weit blickt die Sprachwissenschaft da jetzt zurück? Also was ist die erste gesicherte Erkenntnis?
Gesichert ist da gar nichts. Die ersten schriftlichen Quellen sind so neu. Ja, man kann natürlich schon sich einige Gedanken machen und kann also an bestehenden Sprachen gewisse Merkmale feststellen, die eventuell Möglichkeiten geben, Hypothesen zu bilden darüber, wie das losgegangen ist. Also ein Punkt zum Beispiel, man findet in allen Sprachen irgendwelche Ausdrucksmittel, die was mit zeigen zu tun haben. Das nennt man Dixis oder Dakesis. Na gut, ist das jetzt nicht so wichtig, wie man das nennt. Also man kann mit Sprache irgendwie zeigen, da gibt es so Wörter wie hier und da und dieser und jener. Und natürlich letztlich auch sowas wie ich und du. Das man weiß, dass es ich auf den Sprechern, das du auf den anderen. Und dass es diese Mittel überall gibt, also in allen Sprachen, es ist nicht vorstellbar, dass es eine Sprache ohne das gibt, denkt man, dass das irgendwie etwas ist, was auch ganz am Anfang steht. Und sozusagen in einer Ursprache auch vorhanden gewesen sein muss. Und da diese Zeigeausdrucksmittel auch immer so einen sehr stark gestischen Charakter haben, kann man übrigens auch feststellen, schon an den Wörtern, das, was auf etwas Näherliegendes verweist, hat oft eher einen geschlossenen Vokal, also in ganz vielen Sprachen, und das, was weiter wegweist, hat eher offene Vokale, ist man der Meinung, dass dieser Art Mundgestus auch so was wie eine Zeigegeste mit der Hand abbildet. Und deshalb glauben einige Sprachwissenschaftler, dass der Anfang der Sprache eben tatsächlich in der Gebärdensprache lag. Dass also die ersten Sprecher, also möglicherweise schon die Primaten, die von den Bäumen runtergekommen sind, so eine Mischung aus Laut und Geste hatten. Und dass das praktisch der Anfang der Sprachen ist. Und dass wir dann erst heute in unserer etwas abstrakten Welt dann praktisch den Mund dazugenommen haben. Ja, den Mund dazugenommen haben und einfach nur den Mund letztlich nur noch benutzen und nicht mehr so viel, also nur noch begleiten natürlich mit Gesten.
Durch die Gegend wedeln und keiner weiß mehr, was das eigentlich soll.
Aber das ist praktisch sozusagen das Überbleibsel von dem, was ursprünglich aber im Zentrum der Sprache stand.
Müsste man sich grad mal so einen Vortrag von jemanden anhören und den Ton wegschalten und schauen, ob man allein aus den Gesten auch überhaupt irgendwas ablesen kann? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ja, also wirklich, weiß ich nicht. Ich hab das mal mitgemacht, ich hab mal ein bisschen Gebärdensprache gelernt, da gab es dann immer so Übungen vom Mund ablesen und so. Und man kriegt da schon eine Menge raus, wenn man also auch ungefähr weiß, worum es geht. Also...
Kontext ist wichtig.
Kontext ist ganz wichtig. Das ist ja vor allen Dingen das, was die Sprache so schwierig macht und letztlich auch für automatische Übersetzungen und so, dass halt der Kontext immer ganz wichtig ist. Also das, was der Kontext hergibt, braucht man nicht mehr groß zu versprachlichen. Da reicht es dann eben irgendwo drauf zu zeigen.
Ich wollte eh gerade noch zu Gebärdensprachen kommen, das wir jetzt schon fast vorweggenommen. Ist es nicht so, dass, ich meine, Gebärdensprache, es gibt nicht die eine internationale Gebärdensprache, die alle sprechen, sondern die Gebärdensprachen sind im Prinzip genauso dialectbehaftet oder sind sie an die vorherrschende Muttersprache angelehnt?
Nee, nee, also das mit der Anlehnung an die Muttersprache, das ist nicht der Fall. Also es gibt natürlich immer Entlehnungen aus der Standard-Sprache. Was heißt Muttersprache, das ist jetzt...
Ja, also man jetzt in Deutschland, wenn man jetzt gehörlos ist und man ist in Deutschland, wedelt man dann Deutsch?
Dann gebärdet man deutsche Gebärdensprache.
Man gebärdet, sagt man das so? Wedeln war natürlich kein besonderes technischer Begriff.
Man gebärdet deutsche Gebärdensprache und die ist nicht einheitlich. Die variiert jetzt eben auch von Ort zu Ort. Also von gehörlosen Gemeinschaft zu gehörlosen Gemeinschaft. Das ist da schonmal das Problem. Also wenn man sagt deutsche Gebärdensprache, ist das nicht was Einheitliches, sondern das ist schon sehr unterschiedlich. Natürlich haben all diese Gehörlosen auch Deutsch gelernt und entlehnen natürlich aus dem Deutschen. Also entlehnen da Wörter oder so, die dann auch irgendwie gebärdet werden, aber mit Bezug auf das entlehnte Wort, indem man dazu eben das entsprechende Mundbild des entlehnten Wortes macht oder die Gebärde irgendwie so anpasst, dass man dann noch einen Buchstaben mitgebärdet, um eben auf das entlehnte Wort zu verweisen. Also das ist schon klar. Also das Deutsche spielt eine gewisse Rolle. Aber an sich ist die Gebärdensprache davon unabhängig. Aber, und das ist eben der Punkt, sie ist eben auch nicht einheitlich in Deutschland. Das ändert sich jetzt so ein bisschen, weil es da Bemühungen gibt, das zu vereinheitlichen, und weil auch diese verschiedenen eher lokalen, gehörlosen Gemeinschaften immer mehr auch in Kontakt miteinander treten. Es gibt inzwischen Fernsehprogramme mit Gebärdensprachdol.
Das gibt es ja schon länger.
Jaja, und das führt natürlich zu einer gewissen Vereinheitlichung. Weil man überall in Deutschland dann gehörlose diese Programme sehen und dann auch diese Gebärden sehen und dann eben sagen, aha, dann gebe ich das auch mal so. Wenn die das da in Essen so machen, da kommen die meisten Dolmetscher her, die jetzt im Fernsehen bei Phoenix das machen, soweit ich weiß, und dann wird das eben entsprechend auch übernommen. So gibt es eine gewisse Vereinheitlichung. Das findet natürlich jetzt schon statt.
Gibt es auch ein Videopodcast zur Gebärdensprache? Das wäre ja dann eigentlich auch das Internet geradezu.
Das ist bestimmt eine gute Sache, ja. Das weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber da müsste man sich mal...
Da gucken wir mal...
.dass da findet man vielleicht was.
So, auf den ersten Blick wirft das Internet schon ein paar interessante Links raus. Wir verfolgen das mal. Gut, also von der Gebärdensprache der Frühen zur Begleitbelautung durch den Mund, sag ich mal, weil sicherlich Schreien und Brüllen und Angst und Drohgebären da wahrscheinlich am Anfang eine große Rolle gespielt haben werden. Kann man dann also zur Sprache irgendwann, keine Ahnung, wie zu sagen, welche halbwegs glaubhaften Schätzungen...
Nee, das kann man wirklich nicht schätzen. Irgendwann halt.
Okay, aber was sind denn die ersten verbürgten Dokumente für eine existierende Sprache, also Aufzeichnungen, wo man jetzt wirklich sagen kann, es gab auch eine ausführliche...
Ja, das ist auch schwer zu sagen.
Und das dann die Ägypter, oder?
Ja gut, da haben wir eine richtig voll entwickelte Schriftsprache schon. Aber es gibt natürlich da noch frühere Belege, wo man auch nicht so genau weiß, wenn man sich die Höhlenzeichnungen anschaut, die wir so finden in Lascaux und anderswo, dann könnte es sein, dass das nicht nur Bilder sind, sondern dass da teilweise auch schon etwas mehr Konventionalisiertes drinsteckt. Da gibt es also schon, denkt man schon, dass da vielleicht mehr drinsteckt als nur einfach irgendwelche Abbildungen der Wirklichkeit, sondern schon so was vielleicht.
Dass also jemand, der so abstrakt zu zeichnen in der Lage ist, gegebenenfalls auch schon die abstrakte Sprache erlernt hat.
Genau, und es sind auch nicht alle Zeichen voll interpretiert, die da sind. Da sieht man dann irgendwie so eine Kuh oder so. Und das könnte aber auch, wenn da so mehrere so hintereinander sind, schon eine Art Schrift sein. Das weiß man nicht genau. Aber das könnte man so als...
Vom wissenschaftlichen Zweifel mal abgesehen, wenn du jetzt so deine Zeitmaschine hättest, dann würdest du dich dann sozusagen direkt zu den Affen, die von den Monolithen herumspringen, zurückbieben. Was würdest du dann rechnen, erwarten, was dann passieren würde? Vielleicht laufen die ja alle dann so rum, wie der alte Diogen ist und Philosophieren schon ganz elaboriert. Später gibt es dann so einen frühzeitlichen Atomschlag und dann vergessen sie wieder alles.
Das mit dem Atomschlag würde ich mal ausblenden. Aber ich denke schon, dass man da sehr früh zurückgehen kann und dass man sich dann auch, wenn man tatsächlich mit der Zeitmaschine dahin kommt, muss man ja irgendwie mit diesen Leuten, mit diesen Wesen ins Gespräch kommen und das wird wahrscheinlich sogar gehen. Also da wird man wahrscheinlich was erreichen. Also es wäre ein Versuch wert. Es gibt ja so eine Geschichte von Alfred Bester, wo auch jemand mit der Zeitmaschine herumreißt und dann das Problem stellt, was man normalerweise in den Science-Fictions nicht hat, dass natürlich die Leute nicht alle heutiges Englisch sprechen. Und dass man da ganz große Probleme hat, sich zu verständigen. Aber natürlich ist das möglich, wenn man lange genug dann in der anderen Zeit ist, sich da auch anzupassen. Heute lernt man auch Sprachen, dann lernt man wahrscheinlich auch das ältere Englisch oder was auch immer. Aber das darf man nicht vergessen. Das Reisen mit der Zeitmaschine ist schon sehr beschwerlich, weil man sich da wirklich sehr anpassen muss. Also ich würde es besser lassen.
Aus meinen Zeitreisen kann ich berichten. Ja, stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie schnell ändert sich denn die Sprache? Also wie sehr anders war denn das Deutsch vor 100 Jahren im Vergleich zu heute und beschleunigt sich das eher? Fahren wir jetzt auf so eine universal Einheitssprache zu und es wird immer weniger Dialekte oder gibt es da auch Diversifikation?
Ne, also erstmal ist es so, dass sich Sprache sehr schnell verändert. Das kann man sehr leicht herausfinden, auch im Deutschen. Gut, im Deutschen habe ich es jetzt nicht untersucht, aber ich habe das mal im Italienischen mir ein bisschen angeschaut mit Politikersprache. Also Politiker reden von heute und Politiker reden aus den 60er-Jahren. Da hat man wirklich fast, ist man da der Meinung, die sprechen unterschiedliche Sprachen. Die in den 60er-Jahren bemühen sich... Auf Phönix gibt es ja immer diese schönen, alten Bundestagsdebatten......zu sprechen mit vielen geschwollenen Wörtern, die heute kein Mensch mehr verstehen würde. Wenn die da sagen, ja, allen Talben und so. Und heute ist das völlig ungebräuchlich. Das ist sicherlich auch im Deutschen leicht zu beobachten. Da sieht man also, dass sich die Gewohnheiten doch da relativ schnell verändern und auch so eine gewisse Schwierigkeit im Verstehen eintritt. Das kann man glaube ich wirklich beobachten. Und was jetzt die Vereinheitlichung angeht, da sehe ich das so, dass Leute immer das Bedürfnis haben, in ihrer Peer-Group, in ihrer Familie, in ihrem Freundeskreis, auch diesen Kreis entsprechend zu sprechen. Also sich dann eben neue Wörter zu schaffen, die man nur da in dem Freundeskreis kennt. Also man hat das früher mal untersucht, dass eben Liebespaare da irgendwie besondere Wörter haben, die andere nicht kennen. Und heute kennt man das dann mit dem Teamspeak und anderes, dass es da also eben in Gruppen gewisse sprachliche Besonderheiten gibt.
So wie auch der Chat-Slang. Genau, genau.
Und da sieht man eben, dass es immer das Bedürfnis gibt, sich sprachlich irgendwie abzusondern von anderen. Das heißt also, eine Vereinheitlichung ist auf der Ebene der gesprochenen Sprache so nicht zu erwarten. Klar, in der Schriftsprache sieht das anders aus. Da möchte man halt immer große Mengen Menschen erreichen. Und sicherlich auch beim Podcasten, da wird man auch anders sprechen als im Freundeskreis, wo man auch wieder beim Podcasten anders spricht als in einer offiziellen Nachrichtensendung. Klar. Und da gibt es natürlich auch Tendenzen zu vereinheitlichen.
Klar. Wollte ich gerade was hinterfragen? Ach ja, wie stark sitzt du denn in dem Zusammenhang zwischen der Sprache und der Schrift? Ganz komisch ist die Einwirkung des Internets und der modernen Medien. Auf der einen Seite wird zu viel Fernsehen geguckt, wird zu viel passiv konsumiert, wird zu viel gesprochenes Wort übertragen über Radio und Fernsehen, dass viele Leute einfach nicht mehr so sehr viel schrieben oder schreiben. Es ist die Frage, ob sie das jetzt mehr oder weniger tun. Auf der einen Seite gibt es E-Mail, auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich auch die Sprache in der E-Mail extrem reduziert und auf Kürze gewürzt. Haben wir ja auch schon angesprochen, hier so die Kurzformen im Chat, die damals noch so ein bisschen eher daraus resultierten, dass man so eine geringe Bandbreite hat. Wer lange Worte tippt, muss lange warten, bis er eine Antwort bekommt. Aber dieses Abkürzen ist ja dann auch schon wieder eine eigene Kultur geworden. Manchmal reicht es eben auch total aus, N8 zu schreiben, wenn man sonst vielleicht gesagt hätte, ich gehe dann mal nach Hause. Wie stark ist die Bindung zwischen Sprache und Schrift? Inwieweit entwickelt sich die Sprache mit der Schrift mit? Oder sind das disjunkte Vorgänge?
Das hängt schon zusammen. Die Schriftsprache hat erstmal einen ganz starken Einfluss auf die gesprochene Sprache. Umgekehrt natürlich auch. Da gibt es schon einen engen Zusammenhang. Und das, was immer gesagt wurde, dass durch den Konsum von Fernsehen und so weiter die Schriftsprache irgendwie zurückgeht, weil man das nicht mehr so braucht, das hat sich ja nicht bewahrheitet. Also gerade durch das Internet sind viel mehr Leute schreiben, viel mehr als das früher.
Ja, aber sie schreiben auch so unheimlich viel falsch.
Ja, gut. Das ist noch mal anders.
Oder zumindest, was ist schon falsch, was ist schon richtig, aber anders. Früher hatte ich eigentlich sehr viel mehr Konsistenz bei dem, was ich geschrieben habe. Und das lässt doch schon deutlich nach, gerade bei den Jüngeren.
Ja, klar. Gut, dann weiß man nicht so genau, woran es liegt. Ich meine, die ganze Geschichte mit der Rechtschreibreform hat der einheitlichen Rechtschreibung auch stark geschadet. Denn ich meine, gut, auch im englischen oder französischen Chat hat man gewisse Abweichungen, aber so stark wie im deutschen, glaube ich, das hängt immer davon ab, was man vergleicht, klar. Aber ich denke, dass das Deutsche da besonders gelitten hat, eben auch durch die ganze Sache mit der Rechtschreibreform. Also ich denke nicht, dass das allgemein so ist, dass jetzt aus irgendeinem Grund oder durch den Einsatz des Computers an sich so ein Verfall der Rechtschreibung eintritt. Gut, das müsste man untersuchen, aber ich halte das für nicht einsichtig.
Und ein Verfall der Sprache. Ich habe so gehört, die meisten Leute kommen mit einem Wortschatz aus, der doch sehr gering ist. Weißt du da irgendwelche halbwegs verbundenen Zahlen aus Untersuchungen, wie viele Worte das eigentlich sind, die man heutzutage benötigt?
Ja, da gibt es immer so ein paar schlagkräftige, aussagekräftige Zahlen, denen man aber glaube ich keinen Daumen schenken sollte, wenn dann gesagt wird, heutzutage kommen die Leute mit 300 Wörtern aus oder so. Das halte ich für Quatsch. Vor allen Dingen ist auch nie klar, für was. Also zum Sprechen, zum Schreiben, zum Verstehen. Es ist natürlich klar, dass man passiv sehr viel mehr Wörter kennen, als man wirklich benutzt. Also diese Statistiken würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt glauben.
Hast du nicht selber gefälscht?
Nee, habe ich nicht selber gefälscht.
Ja, das stimmt. Das sind immer diese Worte, wo man dann echt ins Gerügeln kommt, wenn man sie mal wirklich schreiben muss. Wo man sich dann in dem Moment das erste Mal wirklich damit auseinandersetzt. Wie ist denn das jetzt eigentlich? Wenn man es versteht, dann versteht man es sofort. Aber trotzdem ist natürlich vereinheitlich so eine Sache. Man will in seiner Peer-Group da seine eigene Sprache schaffen. Auf der anderen Seite will man sich natürlich auch verständigen können mit möglichst vielen Leuten. Und jetzt ist ja nun genau das mit unserer Internet-Globalisierung findet das ja irgendwie gleichzeitig statt. Die Peer-Group wird immer größer und umspannt auch viele Leute, die noch nicht mal die eigene Muttersprache sprechen. Das heißt, da will man irgendwie eine eigene Sprache haben, aber da muss man sich ja auf irgendwas einigen. Man hat auch so viele Peer-Groups, dass man ja... Genau.
Das habe ich irgendwie vorher nicht mehr richtig ausführen können. Das Problem, was sich heute stellt, ist, dass man ja nicht eine Peer-Group hat, sondern viele. Und dadurch muss man sich auf unterschiedliche sprachliche Register einstellen. Das heißt, jeder Sprecher muss eigentlich sprachlich immer geschickter werden, weil er mehrere Gruppen gleichzeitig bedienen muss. Das war früher nicht so. Früher hatte man, also wenn man sich die traditionelle Gesellschaft anguckt, das Bauernhaus, da musste man in seiner Sippe am Bauernhaus auskommen. Und da musste man sprachlich einigermaßen geschickt sein. Und dann musste man vielleicht noch für die Außenkontakte oder für den Beruf, wenn man noch nicht auf dem Land arbeitete, noch was anderes können. Aber das reichte dann auch schon. Und heute muss man ganz was anderes. Da muss man halt verschiedene Register der Schriftspracher, für den Chat, für das Wiki, für was man auch immer da macht, für seinen Blog, das muss man alles beherrschen, wenn man das machen will.
Und dann auch noch mal der Behörde einen Brief schreiben.
Der Behörde muss mal einen Brief schreiben können. Man muss irgendwie mit seinem Freundeskreis zurechtkommen, mit der Familie und sowas. Also es muss alles, also es muss eine unheimlich breite Kompetenz da sein. Und deshalb, also, und das ist auch vorhanden. Das heißt also, wahrscheinlich, wenn man jetzt mal nur Wörter auszählt, ist der Wortschatz heute, wenn man das alles, wenn man all diese Bereiche mit einschliesst, viel, viel größer als früher.
Ah, okay, also alles nur falscher Alarm.
Ja, es wird halt falsch untersucht, weil man halt dann sagt, ja, wir untersuchen jetzt nur die Schriftsprache, so wie sie in der Schule verwendet wird. Das ist aber nur ein ganz kleiner Ausschnitt der Realität.
Ja, ich meine, wenn ich mir so anschaue, wie viele Kreuzworträtsel auch so verteilt werden, also ist ja auch ein gewisses Training damit verbunden.
Ja, klar.
Keine Ahnung, wie viele Wörter jetzt insgesamt in Kreuzworträtseln so in der Summe überhaupt in Kästchen gefüllt werden, aber das hilft auf jeden Fall auch oder kann zumindest helfen. Bleiben wir aber nochmal bei dieser Vereinheitlichung. Also die Kommunikation zu vereinheitlichen, im Internet ist das ja sozusagen das A und O, in dem Moment, wo man sich auf ein Standard einigt und das lässt sich ja natürlich Programmen sehr leicht beibringen und es ist sehr viel einfacher, umso vereinheitlicher das ist. Solche Trends gab es ja auch bei Sprachen schon längere Zeit. Was sicherlich jeder schon mal gehört hat, ist Esperanto, die große Plansprache oder Kunstsprache. Da kannst du sicherlich gleich nochmal zur Terminologie was sagen. Es gibt noch weitere Interlingua. Du kannst auch Esperanto sprechen, oder? Wie kam das auf und welchen Erfolg haben diese Plansprachen bisher gehabt?
Also, Esperanto kam 1887 auf. 1887. Da ist das erste Buch erschienen, auf Russisch damals. Also, Menschen in der rottnäckigen Sprache. So hieß das Buch und so hieß auch die Sprache. Und der Herausgeber, ein gewisser Dr. Samenhoff, wollte das unter Pseudonym veröffentlichen, weil damals mit der Zensur im Russischen Reich, also er lebt in Warschau, das gehört jetzt zum Russischen Reich, das alles nicht so einfach. Und dann hat er als Pseudonym da drauf geschrieben, Dr. Esperanto. Und das war dann eben die internationale Sprache des Dr. Esperanto. Das immer zu schreiben war den Journalisten auf die Dauer zu lang. Am Anfang gab es ja auch einen richtigen Boom. Also alle wollten darüber berichten, das war was Neues. Das war irgendwie mal eine interessante Idee. Und dann wurde ihm einfach dann gesagt, das Esperanto. Und so kam dann die Sprache zu ihrem Namen.
Der Name selber war einfach so ein Kunstwort, oder bedeutet das auch was?
Esperanto bedeutet auf Esperanto der Hoffende. Und so hat er sich halt genannt, weil er die Hoffnung hatte, dass irgendwie die Welt besser wird, wenn alle Leute eine Sprache sprechen. Das hat er geglaubt und auch immer wieder kommuniziert. Das lag auch an seiner Biografie, weil er eben aus einer mehrsprachigen Gegend kam, im östlichen Polen, wo man also polnisch, litauisch, jädisch und russisch können musste. Und wie gesagt, die Idee war gleich damit verbunden, dass Menschen, die eine Sprache sprechen, auch vielleicht weniger sich hassen. Das war damit einfach an verbunden gewesen. Ja, also am Anfang gab es da richtig gehend so einen Boom, gerade in der gebildeten Gesellschaft. Das fanden alle gut und auch Esperanto hat sich sehr schnell verbreitet und ist sehr schnell bekannt geworden. Und im Gegensatz zu anderen solchen Projekten, die es ja auch vorher schon gab und danach, hatte Samanhoff eine sehr interessante Idee, die aus heutiger Sicht einem bekannt vorkommt. Er hat nämlich gleich in das erste Buch reingeschrieben, dass er auf alle Autorenrechte an dieser Sprache verzichtet. Also sozusagen ein Open-Source-Projekt. Denn er war der Meinung, und damit hat er recht, dass eine Sprache nicht funktionieren kann, wenn die nur von einer Person kontrolliert wird. Sondern es muss irgendwie so ein soziales Ereignis sein. Es müssen Wortschatz und Bedeutungen ausgehandelt werden über eine Sprechergemeinschaft. Das war eben seine Idee. Und das ist halt im Esperanto verwirklicht worden. Und das hat auch zum Erfolg von Esperanto beigetragen, weil da jeder gleichberechtigt mitwirken konnte. Das hat natürlich viele Leute dann auch angestachelt, da mitzumachen.
Also so ein bisschen dieser Wikipedia-Effekt. Ich würde jetzt mal eher sagen, freies Wissen als Open Source. Das trifft ja vielleicht auch eher Free Software, wenn man schon den Software-Vergleich bemühen möchte. Aber schon eigentlich eher die Idee des Wissens im öffentlichen Raum. Freies Wissen passt besser. Und gut, Erfolg von Esperanto. Was ist denn der Erfolg? Also ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass man jetzt über die Straße läuft und dann hat man so Werbung in Esperanto und dann bricht einfach sonst keiner irgendwie in der U-Bahn drauf an.
Soweit ist es halt nicht gekommen. Es ist halt dann irgendwie im Bereich des Idealismus geblieben. Und ja, bis heute. Also es gibt ja immer noch sehr, sehr viele Esperanto-Sprecher. Genaue Zahlen gibt es da nicht. Wegen der fehlenden Meldepflicht.
Das wäre schön, was?
Nehmen wir mal an, also man kommt da schon vielleicht.
Aber es gibt ja sicherlich jetzt Esperanto-Gemeinden im Internet, oder?
Genau, nur im Internet.
Webseiten, tralala, das übliche.
Also man kann da sehr schnell herausfinden, wo es andere Sprecher gibt und sich mit denen treffen.
Bist du da auf irgendwelchen Esperanto-Mailing-Listen eingetragen?
Jaja, sicher, klar.
Und da wird dann auch ordentlich geschwatzt?
Da wird dann ordentlich geschwatzt, aber...
Sind alle Esperanto gut?
Ja, also die, mit denen ich zusammen getroffen bin, und das sind wirklich eine ganze Menge, sind eigentlich alle ganz fit. Es ist eben auch nicht so schwer zu lernen. Das muss man einfach mal sagen.
Aber wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Also ich meine, ist das cool irgendwie? Man kommt dann irgendwie so in ein Haus, wo ein Wochenende trifft sich, und dann schwatzen halt alle die ganze Zeit auf Esperanto.
Genau, ja das ist schon cool, so eine etwas ausgefallene Sprache zu sprechen.
Und da fällt keiner irgendwie in seine eigene Sprache zurück, wenn man merkt, dass er dann parallel ist?
Nö, also das ist gerade das Faszinierende, dass man da sehr schnell auf ein gutes Niveau kommt und eigentlich kein Problem hat, dass da irgendwie zurückfällt so ein bisschen.
Aber so eine Sprache muss man ja auch laufend lernen, weil es gibt Entwicklungen, es gibt Begriffe, was weiß ich, was heißt Internet auf Esperanto? Internet, oder?
Interretto.
Aha, Interretto.
Also Inter, kennt man, und Retto ist halt das Netz.
Interretto. Und, gut, das ist natürlich sehr naheliegend, aber...
Ja gut, aber man muss es wissen. Also wenn man es nicht weiß, dann sagt man vielleicht Internetto.
Genau, oder auch so Begriffe, die so in der Diskussion sind. Es ist ja in dem Sinne nichts in der Diskussion, in der Esperanto-Welt, weil es... Worüber sollte man sich schon unterhalten, außer über Esperanto?
Man kann über alles Mögliche sich unterhalten. Also das tut man ja auch normalerweise. Man spricht ja jetzt nicht nur über Esperanto, sondern wenn man sich trifft, spricht man halt über das Internet, über den neuen iPod oder sonst was. Ist ja klar.
Und was heißt iPod dann auf Esperanto? Nicht ernsthaft? Doch. Wirklich? Und das heißt dann was?
PODO ist also POD ist halt das... Die Wurzel aus iPod eben. Und IL ist eine Endung für Werkzeug. Also sozusagen das Werkzeug zum Poden. Also PODI wäre dann sowas wie, weiß ich nicht, Podcasten. Nee, ohne cast. Cast ist also auch da was anderes. Ich hab allerdings auch Podcasto schon gesehen. Also da sieht man, das ist noch so auf der Ebene ausgehandelt.
Okay, also da klärt es sich sozusagen. Aber das klärt sich gerade. Okay, aber es gibt da eine Szene und die hat solche Themen und die setzt sich dann natürlich auch damit genau auseinander.
Und wenn man halt jetzt irgendwie nicht richtig teilnimmt an der Sprachgemeinschaft, kriegt man das natürlich alles nicht mit und hat natürlich dann tatsächlich erst mal ein Verständnungsproblem. Aber das gibt sich dann sehr schnell, weil man sehr schnell mitbekommt, was denn nun gesagt wird. Und wenn ich dann irgendwie auf so ein Esperantotreffen fahre und immer Podcasto sage, werde ich irgendwann auch merken, dass die anderen alle irgendwie was anderes sagen und dann sage ich eben das andere.
Nun ist Esperanto ja nicht die einzige Sprache in dieser Form. Was empfindest du da noch als erwähnenswert, außer Esperanto?
Naja, es gibt natürlich andere Projekte, die dann nicht so viel Zulauf hatten, aber natürlich auch interessant sind. Also vielleicht...
Interlingua ist noch eine, die auch sehr im Lateinischen verwurzelt ist, oder?
Die ist noch etwas stärker dem Lateinischen verwurzelt. Das Esperanto hat so ein besonderes Wortbildungssystem, was die Sprache sehr aussagefähig macht, was aber jetzt nicht unbedingt so ist, wie wir das aus den europäischen Sprachen kennen. Oder aus den, sagen wir mal, kringigen Schulsprachen kennen. Und Interlingua ist halt stärker angepasst an die romanischen Sprachen, von der Grammatik her.
Aber Latein so als übergreifende Sprache, meine, gibt es ja auch nicht wirklich. Man taugt Latein nicht. Warum hat man nicht gleich Latein genommen?
Latein ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig zu lernen. Ein Aspekt bei Esperanto ist eben, dass es leicht zu lernen sein soll. Es gibt keine Ausnahmen, es war das regelmäßig. Das führt eben auch dazu, dass die Grammatik nicht so sehr romanisch ist. Dieser starke Hang zur Regelmäßigkeit. Das hat an einigen Leuten nicht gepasst. Das haben sie in der Lingua ins Leben gerufen. Zu Latein gibt es auch ein Projekt, nämlich Latinos Vine Fleccione. Das ist ein Latein ohne Fleccione. Das ist auch eine Kunstsprache auf lateinischer Basis. Sie nimmt halt den gesamten lateinischen Wortschatz und verwendet das dann ohne Fleccionsendungen. Das ist auch ein Projekt, aber das hat auch nicht so viel Zulauf gefunden. Es ist trotzdem immer noch.
Findet denn überhaupt irgendetwas Zulauf? Es gibt ja auch jetzt noch ein paar jüngere Entwicklungen. Mir würde jetzt Lojban einfallen.
Genau, das hätte ich als nächstes genannt.
Hättest du als nächstes genannt, dann mach das doch mal.
Also es gibt natürlich auch sehr interessante Projekte. Also ich persönlich finde jetzt so Sachen wie Interlingua oder Oriental oder wie auch immer, die heißen alle nicht so sehr interessant, erstmal weil sie nicht so viel Zulauf haben und weil sie im Grunde immer wieder dieselbe Idee darstellen. Letztlich auch für Esperanto. Und da kann es Esperanto einfach besser. Was etwas anders ist, sind eben solche Sprachen wie Lojban oder der Vorläufer Loklan, die ein anderes Konzept haben. Also Loklan ist damals eher entwickelt worden, um Logik direkt zu versprachlichen. Und eigentlich mit so einer wissenschaftlichen Zielsetzung oder weiß ich nicht ob wirklich wissenschaftlich, aber es ging eben darum zu prüfen, ob wirklich Menschen durch die Sprache, die sie sprechen, in irgendeiner Weise beeinflusst sind. Und um das zu testen, hat eben der Autor von Loklan, jetzt weiß ich nicht genau den Namen, Moment, da muss ich mal kurz nachschauen. Wofür haben wir das Internet? Ja, James Cook Brown. In den 50er Jahren eben eine Plansprache entwickelt, die halt auf Logik basiert, die also die Prädikatenlogik versprachlicht, damit man die Möglichkeit hat, sich wirklich logisch, also völlig logisch auszudrücken und damit eben zu überprüfen, inwiefern die Sprache das Denken beeinflusst. Denn eine rein logische Sprache dürfte das Denken jetzt nicht besonders beeinflussen.
Eine rein logische Sprache dürfte das Denken nicht beeinflussen?
Diese Hypothese, die dahinter liegt, das sogenannte sprachliche Relativitätsprinzip, sagt, dass Sprecher dadurch, dass sie eine bestimmte Sprache sprechen, auch in gewisser Weise denken, weil die Sprache Kategorisierungen vornimmt. Das ist von Sprache zu Sprache unterschiedlich. Zum Beispiel die Welt einteilt in nominaren Verben, das ist nicht immer in allen Sprachen gleich. Und dann ist man halt irgendwie, wenn man eine bestimmte Sache immer als Nomen sich vorstellt, da auch irgendwie im Denken voreingenommen. Oder eine andere Sache ist das Genus. Wenn eine Sprache irgendwie ein Genus hat, dann haben wir irgendwelche Vorstellungen davon, dass halt die Sonne männlich ist und der Mond weiblich oder umgekehrt, je nach unserer Sprache. Und das sollte halt irgendwie wegfallen. Und diese Art der Kategorisierung fällt halt bei Loklern weg. Es ist also nur noch die Prädikatenlogik da. Also hat also ein Wort. Dieses Wort kann man einsetzen in so einem Logikprädikat. Dann gehört natürlich zu dem Wort, gehören natürlich bestimmte Relationen. Also ein Wort wie gehen hat dann bestimmte, da muss man dann jemanden dabei haben, der geht, ein Ziel dabei haben, irgendwo wo man herkommt und so. Und das wird dann halt in so einem Prädikat eingebunden.
Kannst du das mal irgendwie mit einem Beispiel auskleiden, wie das so klingen würde, wenn man es da wieder in Deutsch zurückkriegt?
Machen wir gleich bei Lojban. Einmal, weil Loklan urheberrechtlich geschützt ist. Und zweitens, weil Lojban wirklich eher den Sprachcharakter hat. Ich wollte jetzt nur von der Geschichte her anfangen bei Loklan. Das war also die erste Idee. Loklan ist eigentlich keine wirklich sprechbare Sprache. Das ist also eigentlich nur Logik. Das war also schon mal ein Problem. Dann gab es eine Gruppe, die wollte da jetzt wirklich eine Sprache rausmachen. So wie eine internationale Sprache. Und da hat man aber neu angefangen. Weil man sich überlegt hat, man muss etwas von der Logik wegkommen und stärker an die Sprachen ran. Das heißt, man muss irgendwelche Ausgangssprachen haben, aus denen man die Wörter bekommt. Die sollen dann aber auch in die neue logische Sprache integriert werden nach einem bestimmten Algorithmus, dass man am Wort auch schon erkennt, was das für eine Art von Wort ist und so. Also das sollte alles dazukommen. Und das ist eben diese Neuentwicklung von Logline, ist eben Lojban.
Wie neu ist die?
Oh, wie neu ist die? Aus den 80er Jahren. Mal schnell nachschauen.
Also nicht wirklich super.
Ja, 1987 hat das angefangen. Ja, da hat also sich eine Gruppe hingesetzt, also wirklich auch wieder jetzt eine offene Sprache, im Sinne von freiem Wissen. Das ist also wieder anders als bei Logline und eben genauso wie bei Esperanto, zu entwickeln, also auf der Grundlage der Logik. Und zwar auch jetzt eine Sprache, die man sprechen kann und schreiben kann, die also stärker diesen Sprachcharakter hat. Also eine ganz wichtige Neuerung, die auch ganz wichtig ist bei Sprachen, ist, dass man vieles einfach unausgedrückt lassen kann. Das hatten wir ja vorhin schon, dass der Kontext halt über vieles entscheidet. Und das ist auch zum Prinzip erklärt worden bei Lojban. Wenn also Sachen klar sind, muss man die nicht nochmal ausdrücken. Ich kann also die Tempos-Markierung weglassen, wenn ich eh weiß, ich erzähle jetzt was in der Vergangenheit, dann ist das klar und dann geht es auch ohne Tempos-Markierung. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Sache.
Und man schreibt alles klein?
Nein, man schreibt auch manchmal Sachen groß. Da gibt es so bestimmte Regeln, zum Beispiel, wenn der Akzent unregelmäßig ist, schreibt man die akzentuierte Silbe groß. Also normalerweise wird alles auf der vorletzten Silbe betont. Und wenn man jetzt irgendwie einen eigenen Namen hat, den man anders betont, dann schreibt man die Silbe mit Großbuchstaben.
Warum wird hier so übermisst? Ich blicke hier gerade auf die Wikipedias, also die in Lojban geschriebenen Wikipedias. Und das sind ja eine ganze Menge Apostrophe mit dem Wort.
Ja, genau, das Apostrophe ist auch ein Buchstabe dort.
Das Apostrophe ist ein Buchstabe?
Ja, also das ist auch da in dem Konzept mit drin.
Das Apostrophe ist ein H. Warum hat er nicht gleich ein H genommen?
Das weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, warum er nicht gleich ein H genommen hat. Aber das Apostrophe steht da jedenfalls für ein H.
Aber die Sprache ist auf jeden Fall so logisch, dass sie sich auch relativ leicht mit einem Computer interpretieren lässt?
Genau, also es liegt natürlich daran, dass man jetzt wieder die Prädikatenlogik verwendet. Und das heißt also, man arbeitet nicht wie normalerweise, das heißt normalerweise in vielen Sprachen damit, dass man halt so eine Umwerbunterscheidung hat, sondern es gibt da eben ein zugrundeliegend, also eine grundlegende Syntax, die auf der Prädikatenlogik beruht. Das heißt, man macht also so eine logische Aussage. Das kann man sich ganz gut vorstellen, das kann man sehr schön auch sehen in der Wikipedia, auf der Lojban-Seite, da gibt es sehr schöne Beispiele. Da ist also dieser schöne Satz, mi clama la Paris, la Hamburg, la Cologne, la Carte.
Köln, Hamburg und Paris sind alle schöne Orte.
Ich fahre von Paris nach Paris. Zuerst kommt immer das, wohin man fährt. Das Bewegungsziel, dann der Bewegungsausgangspunkt. Das ist also Hamburg. Dann über welchen Ort man fährt. Zum Schluss kommt das Instrument. Das ist genau festgelegt, diese Reihenfolge.
Ist das wirklich einfacher?
Nee, das ist nicht einfacher. Das ist jetzt der große Unterschied zwischen Lojban und Esperanto. Esperanto versucht wirklich, möglichst einfach zu sein. Das kann man wirklich schnell lernen. Ich hab ja auch schon Kurse veranstaltet. Wenn man beim Esperanto weiß, alle Verben enden im Präsens auf As. Dann sagt man in der Vergangenheit auf Is. Dann kann jeder einen Text aus dem Präsens auch in der Vergangenheit erzählen. Das macht man mit einer anderen Sprache. Das ist nicht so einfach. Das geht bei Lojban auch. Da gibt es eine Partikel für die Vergangenheit. Das wäre auch einfach. Aber diese Prädikatenlogik ist nicht ohne. Man muss also immer wissen, welche Argumente ein Verb haben kann, was da noch dazustehen kann und was das sein muss. Das ist natürlich im Lexikon festgelegt, aber das muss ich halt wissen. Dann muss ich den Satz so bauen, dass ich tatsächlich alle diese Dinge erfülle oder einfach was weglasse. Das geht natürlich. Deshalb gibt es auch die bestimmte Ordnung. Das, was man am häufigsten verwendet, zum Beispiel gehen, das Ziel, das kommt natürlich zuerst, sodass ich die anderen Sachen leichter weglassen kann. Also das ist schon so ein bisschen, es ist schon durchdacht. Aber ich muss halt das logische Muster wissen. Und das ist nicht so ganz einfach. Also es ist schon, also in Logik zu sprechen, ist an sich schwierig. Und deshalb ist Lojban nicht...
Das merkt man auch, wenn man sich Vorträge anhört.
Deshalb ist Lojban nicht so leicht. Ich denke, es ist relativ gut zu handeln, wenn man es schreibt. Also so im Internet, auch sogar noch im Chat geht es ganz gut. Aber zu sprechen ist es schon nicht einfach. Also ich kenne ein paar Leute, die ziemlich gut Lojban können. Und naja, also ich kann es jetzt nicht so beurteilen, wie gut die sprechen. Aber die meisten von denen tun es sich leichter, wenn sie Esperanto sprechen. Interessanterweise die Lojban-Sprecher, die ich kenne, bis auf einen, da weiß ich es nicht genau, aber zwei Lojban-Sprecher kenne ich, die sprechen auch Esperanto. Das können sie offensichtlich leichter.
Bei meiner Reise jüngst durch, wo war ich, in Bulgarien, bin ich auf Slowio getroffen. Sagt dir das was? Nee. Das finde ich toll. Slowio ist auch gar keine Sprache in dem Sinne, sondern es ist lediglich eine Schreibform für alle slawischen Sprachen. Das heißt, man hat versucht, alle slawischen Sprachen, die ja gerade in der Schriftform teilweise sehr unterschiedlich sind, also Bulgarien zum Beispiel verwendet ja Kyrillisch und andere verwenden ja eben das lateinische Alphabet. Serbien auch Kyrillisch. Also das ist halt alles durcheinander und auch bestimmte Grundlaute, die es überall gibt, schreiben sich halt im Polnischen ganz anders. Und Slowio ist eine vereinfachte Schreibform und ich fand es erstaunlich, weil es waren, in der Runde, wo ich war, waren halt Muttersprachler quer durch ganz Osteuropa vertreten. Und alle konnten den Text sofort lesen. Also alle haben sich vor diese Webseite gesetzt, da stand dann halt was in Slowio und alle wussten sofort, was gemeint war. Und zwar nicht so in etwa, sondern sie waren sich auch total sicher. Das fand ich doch relativ beeindruckend, weil das ja im Prinzip auch zeigt, dass so eine Vereinheitlichung in dem Sinne auch möglich ist. Dass man es schon auch irgendwie schaffen kann, das immer weiter zu vereinfachen.
Aber gibt es da nicht auch falsche Freunde? Also ich meine, es gibt ja in den slawischen Sprachen sehr viele Ähnlichkeiten, aber ein Wort in der einen Sprache heißt ja möglicherweise etwas ganz anderes in der anderen Sprache, obwohl es formal ähnlich ist.
Also meine Kenntnisse in slawischen Sprachen sind leider nicht existent, von daher konnte ich das nicht groß überprüfen. Ich konnte mich nur auf die Aussagen aller Leute dort verlassen. Da waren Leute aus Kroatien, da waren Serben, da waren Ungarn, Rumänen, Bulgarier, also es scheint auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Projekt zu sein, auch wenn es uns vielleicht uns im romanischen Sprachraum nicht so unmittelbar war, betrifft. Sind wir eigentlich in Deutschland auch im romanischen Sprachraum? Nein, sind wir nicht. Wir sind hier germanisch. Aber es gibt ja Einflüsse, das sind sogenannte Fremdworte. Voll von Fremdworten sind ja, ich weiß nicht, man nennt das glaube ich, konstruierte Sprachen. So was wie zum Beispiel Klingonisch. Das ist ja eigentlich eher mal so als Scherz entstanden, also im Rahmen von Star Trek. Hast du schon mal irgendwie Klingonisch dir angeschaut?
Ja, habe ich mir angeschaut. Ich habe auch ein kleines Paper dazu verfasst. In Klingonisch? Nein, nicht in Klingonisch. Zur Typologie von Klingonisch. Das interessante bei Klingonisch ist ja, dass da der Versuch gemacht wurde, möglichst eine unmenschliche Sprache, unmenschlich ging ganz komisch, eine Sprache zu machen, die irgendwie ganz anders ist, als die Sprachen, die man so auf der Erde spricht. Und da gibt es ja einige Forschungen darüber, was so die menschlichen Sprachen, was so die menschlichen Sprachen gemeinsam haben. Und da gab es gerade in den 60er-, 70er-Jahren ein großes Forschungsprojekt in Stanford über sogenannte Language Universals, also Sprachuniversalien. Und der Initiator von Klingonisch, der Mark Ockrand, hat offensichtlich, das merkt man der Sprache sehr deutlich an, an der Westküste der Vereinigten Staaten Linguistik studiert. Und hat diese ganzen Erkenntnisse verarbeitet. Da drin hat es dann also immer anders gemacht. Also Laute, die möglichst selten vorkommen, sind dann, die selten vorkommen auf der Welt, kommen halt Klingonischen besonders häufig vor. Wortstellungen, die ganz selten sind, unter den Sprachen der Welt. Also ist das Objekt-Verb Subjekt, ist die Grundwortstellung des Klingonischen. Also immer diese...
Einfach andersrum.
Einfach andersrum, genau. Dennoch...
Haus ich baue.
Haus baue ich. Dennoch ist das Klingonische, wenn man sich das genau anschaut, doch sehr, ja, irgendwie sogar indogamanisch. Die Wörter sind zwar alle anders, aber die Grammatik erinnert dann doch irgendwie sehr ans Englische. Also es ist schon, gut, es ist eine polysynthetische Sprache, das heißt, es funktioniert so wie in den amerikanischen Indianer Sprachen. Also da sind also sehr viele, ja, Pronomina, das muss man jetzt eigentlich als erklären, am Verb mit dran.
Ja.
Also an einem Verb ist halt immer dran, wer etwas tut und wem er etwas antut, das ist so mit dran am Verb. Das ist schon etwas exotisch, weil das halt in den nordamerikanischen Indianer Sprachen eher entspricht als den indogermanischen Sprachen, also aus indogermanischer Sicht exotisch, aber das ist trotzdem alles wiederzufinden in den Sprachen der Welt. Also es ist eigentlich keine gute Sprache für Außerirdische.
Gut, jetzt müssen wir den Bogen mal schließen, weil ich wollte natürlich auch da nochmal auf Sprachen zu sprechen kommen, die uns natürlich jetzt in der Computergemeinde immer bewegt, nämlich die Purmiersprachen. Was hast du da für ein Verhältnis zu und inwieweit siehst du da überhaupt jetzt Analogien zu der Art und Weise? Ich meine, man verwendet ja meist englische Anleihen und dann gibt es Sprachen, die sehen doch sehr mathematisch aus, andere Sprachen wiederum lesen sich schon fast wie Fließtext. Was hast du da für Erfahrungen sammeln können?
Gut, also ich denke, Programmiersprachen, also das Wort Sprache da ist anders verwendet, ist halt so eine Art Metapher. Es geht ja schon darum, da eher formal zu codieren, was der Computer als nächstes machen soll. Das ist schon mal was anderes. Dennoch wird da von Sprachen gesprochen. Und es gibt natürlich Projekte schon ganz von Anfang an, wo es ein eher engeres Verhältnis zur Sprache gibt. Nämlich Lisp zum Beispiel ist ja eine Sprache, die auch wiederum auf Logik basiert, die also sehr logiknah ist und deshalb natürlich auch vielleicht besser geeignet ist, zum Beispiel irgendwelche Probleme zu lösen, die was mit Sprache zu tun haben. Oder Prolog, die ja als diskriptive Programmiersprache auch direkt auf Logik aufsetzt und deshalb eben auch sprachnah ist. Und da kann man dann auch...
Also weil sie quasi mit einer Aussage arbeitet.
Ja, genau.
Mit Wahrheits...
Genau, Aussagen, Logik und das ist halt, wir hatten das vorhin schon bei Logladen und Lojban, da gibt es ein enges Verhältnis oder ein engeres Verhältnis zur Sprache als in den prozeduralen Programmiersprachen, wo man halt einen Befehl nach dem anderen absetzt. So funktioniert halt Sprache nicht. Also wenn man sich unterhält, gibt man keine Befehle ab.
Ja gut, aber man kommuniziert und man versucht ja auch schon auch irgendwas zu bewirken und Informationen zu vermitteln. Und ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass sich im Internet im Prinzip Programmiersprachen und Protokolle weiter annähern. Das erlebt man ja jetzt auch schon. Man hat so zunehmende Maße prozeduralere Interfaces, Webseiten sind nicht nur zum Angucken da, sondern Web-Server-Antworten, mittlerweile komplex auf Anfragen von Programm, Leiten, Daten formalisiert weiter. Es gibt immer mehr Beschreibungssprachen, gefördert durch diesen einheitlichen Wortschatz-XML. Kann man halt jetzt anfangen darauf, oder sagen wir mal eine einheitlichen Syntax-XML und darauf dann basieren eben die ganzen Wortschätze, die Semantiken dieser ganzen Sachen. Könnte ich das schon ablesen? Gibt es da irgendwas, was dir dazu...
Ich denke, da gibt es schon interessante Entwicklungen, wo man auch wirklich noch gar nicht genau weiß, wohin die Reise geht, aber wo man sich schon Sachen überlegen kann. Also einfach dadurch, dass zum Beispiel verschiedensprachige Texte miteinander verknüpft werden im Internet. Also es ist ein banales Beispiel, zum Beispiel die Interwikilinks in der Wikipedia. Da hat man halt praktisch ungefähr denselben Text, also immerhin einen sehr ähnlichen Text, miteinander, also in verschiedenen Sprachen verknüpft hat. Gibt es natürlich Möglichkeiten, das irgendwann auszunutzen. Zum Beispiel in der automatischen Übersetzung könnte das einen großen Schritt nach vorne bringen, aber auch sonst, also überhaupt Strukturierung von Wissen, da gibt es ja dieses große Problem mit den sogenannten Ontologien, dass man sich halt irgendwie versucht, Begriffe zu erschließen oder Begrifflichkeiten zu erschließen und ich denke, da gibt es eine interessante Entwicklung, weil sich eben doch die ganze Informatik wandelt, die ja eigentlich daher rührt, dass man mit Zahlen zunächst umgegangen ist. Und dann kam vielleicht so eine, ja Computer, da wurde gezählt, dann kam vielleicht so eine Phase, wo man mit Wörtern umgegangen ist, aber jetzt geht es zu allen darum, Texte zu bearbeiten und sich mit Texten auseinanderzusetzen und Texte zu erschließen. Und das ist natürlich ein ganz neuer, oder Daten im Allgemeinen, das geht ja schon über Texte hinaus, Zusammenhänge, Data-Mining. Genau, aber ich denke, der Text spielt immer noch eine ganz wichtige Rolle, also Bilder zu erschließen oder so, das ist zwar auch ein wichtiges Feld, aber so ganz textfrei geht das auch nicht. Also ich denke...
Also eine Ontology Markup-Language ist auch schon in der Arbeit, also das Versprechen des semantischen Webs, das ist glaube ich das, was du jetzt auch ansprichst.
Genau, da gibt es ganz interessante Entwicklungen, die jetzt wirklich am Anfang sind, die aber einfach kommen müssen, weil es immer mehr darum geht, immer größere Mengen von, ja, Daten ist jetzt eigentlich falsch, es ist schon Pex, also es ist irgendwas erstmal nicht strukturiertes an Informationsträger, was aber irgendwie strukturiert werden muss und erfasst ist.
Na gut, auch die Daten im Netz sind ja in dem Sinne nicht von vornherein strukturiert. Du bist ja auch schon sehr lange bei der Wikipedia mit aktiv. Welche Bedeutung hat denn so die Wikipedia für die sprachforschende Szene gehabt? Und was ich auch ganz gerne mal wissen würde, was sich so mit Wiktionary eigentlich abzeichnet.
Ja, also bisher, die Wikipedia selbst in der sprachforschenden Szene hat da eher weniger Eingang gefunden, obwohl es da wirklich interessante Fragenstellungen gibt, die man angeben sollte in nächster Zeit. Also ich will da auch selber einen Vorstoß machen. Was ich halt sehr, sehr spannend finde, ist die Geschichte mit den Interwiki-Links. Und was verbirgt sich auf der anderen Seite dieses Links? Denn wir wissen ja, das ist ja nicht eine 1 zu 1 Übersetzung, was da in der anderen Wikipedia steht. Und jetzt wäre es herauszufinden, welche systematischen Unterschiede bestehen.
In der Herangehensweise etwas zu beschreiben.
Genau, also nicht nur, dass jetzt mal ein Artikel kürzer ist, weil die samoanische Wikipedia noch nicht so weit ist, aber es wäre auf jeden Fall interessant zu sehen, ob nicht systematische Unterschiede zum Beispiel in der Struktur der Artikel zu finden sind zwischen den verschiedenen Sprachen. Das wäre auch vor dem Hintergrund dieser Sache mit dem Determinismus, den wir vorhin angesprochen haben, interessant. Also Sprache ist sicherlich mehr als nur so ein paar Vokabeln, sondern da stecken vielleicht auch Herangehensweisen drin, wie man Texte aufbaut und so, dass das alles überhaupt noch nicht untersucht war, weil man das einfach nicht konnte in der Vergangenheit. Man hatte da kein vergleichbares Material. Und hier haben wir es. Und deshalb, da ist ganz dringender Forschungsbedarf. Da müsste man eigentlich sofort ein Forschungsantrag machen.
Und Wiktionary, dieses Schwesterprojekt von der Wikipedia, macht das so? Ich habe das mir jetzt schon länger nicht mehr angeschaut. Macht das Fortschritte oder dümpelt das?
Unterschiedlich in den verschiedenen Sprachen. Da sind die Deutschen jetzt mal nicht so richtig top, wie bei der Wikipedia. Ich finde ja, die deutsche Wikipedia ist eigentlich die Wikipedia schlechthin. Also, die hat gegenüber der Englischen einige wirklich gute Vorteile und sie ist nach der Englischen ja die größte.
Welche Vorteile siehst du da?
Kannst du nebenbei? Ja, es sind ganz verschiedene Sachen. Einmal, denke ich, ist die deutsche Wikipedia insgesamt etwas einheitlicher. Bei der englischen Wikipedia findet man ja natürlich alles Mögliche. Da sieht man oft nicht so sehr den roten Faden, was nun die Sache angeht, was man noch rein nimmt und was man nicht rein nimmt. Das ist bei der deutschen ein bisschen anders. Außerdem, ideologisch gesehen, finde ich es einfach besser, dass man in der deutschen Wikipedia den ursprünglichen Gedanken, dass jeder da mitmachen kann, auch ohne Anmeldung, besser. In der englischen ist ja so, dass man keine Artikel neu anlegen kann, wenn man nicht angemeldet ist. Also ich finde einfach, das sind jetzt zwei Aspekte. Es gibt noch ein paar andere Aspekte.
Ich denke, zu Wikipedia sollte man in absehbarer Zeit auch noch mal ein Podcast machen. Das gibt wieder eine Menge her.
Da kann ich auch viel zu sagen. Da gibt es auch eine andere, die da eine ganze Menge dazu sagen kann.
Mich interessiert vor allem also aus dem sprachkulturellen Aspekt. Ich war jetzt auch gerade in Serbien und durfte ich halt auch erfahren, bin halt auch mit der lokalen Wikipedia-Gemeinde aufeinander getroffen, war ganz überrascht, dass, obwohl die serbischen Sprache und die kroatische Sprache ja eigentlich, ich weiß nicht, wie du das sehen würdest, also ich würde mal sagen, mindestens die gleiche ist, wenn es vielleicht auch nicht dieselbe ist. Wikipedia-Projekte da auf jeden Fall separat sind, das hat natürlich vor allem geschichtliche, kulturelle Gründe. Aber auch da wäre es natürlich interessant mal nachzuhaken, forschend, ob sozusagen die Herangehensweise da in irgendeiner Form...
Ja, auch das wäre interessant.
Unterschiedlich ist es.
Da wäre man so an der Schnittstelle Kulturwissenschaft, Sprachwissenschaft, aber das wäre auf jeden Fall spannend. Also selbst nur in diesem kleinen Bereich, aber da ist das natürlich sehr politisch. Also das ist ein sehr politischer Spaß. Also um nochmal zum Victionary zurückzukommen. Also da sind andere Sprachen etwas weiter als die Deutschen. Also das französische Victionary hat doch sehr viele Eindrücke. Können wir schnell nachgucken, wie viele. Das findet man ja relativ schnell.
Die Franzosen sind ja eigentlich auch sprachnahren.
Jaja, das merkt man eben auch daran.
Und die Deutschen sind sozusagen eher so Lexikon-Narren.
Ja, genau. Und auch die Italiener sind da relativ weit beim Victionary. Also das heißt relativ weit, also jedenfalls deutlich weiter als die Deutschen.
Vielleicht sind die Sprachen einfacher.
Nee, das Französische ist jetzt nicht unbedingt eine einfache Sprache, würde ich sagen. Also gut, ja.
Naja, so mit Fällen und so, das ist ja irgendwie alles schon mal.
Ja, jetzt bin ich auf der Französischen Victionary. 304.000 Artikel. Lass mal vergleichen mit dem Deutschen Victionary.
Das sollten wir nochmal. Realtime, Data, Research. Das können wir machen. Solange das Internet noch läuft.
Ja, genau. Also wie gesagt, die Franzosen sind da sehr weit. Da gibt es auch wohl eine richtige Community dahinter. Gut, die gibt es in Deutschland auch, aber die ist nicht so stark wie die Wikipedia-Community. Gut, das ist in Frankreich auch so, dass die nicht so stark ist, aber sie ist doch deutlich stärker, weil eben das Interesse versprochen ist. Ja, Deutsches Victionary, 44.000 Einträge.
Also die haben achtfache. Interessant.
Also da sieht man schon einen deutlichen Unterschied. Und das, ja. Aber ich denke, ich habe mich jetzt nicht mit den verschiedenen kleineren Wiktionaries beschäftigt. Aber ich denke, das bietet wirklich schon schöne Möglichkeiten. Also viele Sprachen, die sich sonst kein wirklich großes Lexikon so ohne Weiteres leisten, hätten hier eine Möglichkeit.
Ja, vor allem auch so Sprachen, von denen man gar nicht mehr so richtig weiß, dass es überhaupt gibt. Also es gibt ja was zum plattdeutschen, ich glaube NDS ist das Wikipedia. Es gibt alemannische Wikipedia. Ob die jetzt irgendwann nochmal wirklich viel und nachschlagenwürdigen Inhalte enthalten werden, weiß ich nicht, aber es ist zumindest ein Beitrag, dieses Aussterben der Sprachen auch zu verhindern. Droht das? Droht, ja. Also wie viele Sprachen gibt es in Deutschland, so jetzt mal vom Gruppstamm her?
Wie viele Sprachen es in Deutschland gibt?
Ja, ich meine, was muss man sagen, es gibt so das Bayrische und dann gibt es so das Schwäbische.
Das kann man alles nicht so richtig zählen, weil natürlich das Bayrische ist ja auch das große Problem bei der Bayrischen Wikipedia. Welches Bayrisch nimmt man da? Da haben die gesagt, naja irgendein Bayrisch. Also da muss man schon so ein bisschen anders dran gehen.
Okay, wir können jetzt die Probleme von Wikipedia auch nicht hier lösen. Wollten wir auch gar nichts, sondern wir wollten über Sprachen reden, das haben wir auch gemacht. Ich sag mal, vielen Dank, gibt es noch irgendwie ein Abschlusswort, wo ich dich zu sehr unterbrochen habe?
Ja, hast du öfter.
Habe ich öfter? Na ja, man muss ja auch den Fluss sicherstellen, ne?
Also da kann man zu vielen Sachen noch eine ganze Menge sagen. Aber ich denke, du machst ja auch noch Links dazu. Und dann können sich die Leute ja über die verschiedenen Punkte, die wir angesprochen haben, selber ein Bild machen.
Genau, Chaosradio Express kommt auch deshalb immer so selten, weil ich mir so viel Mühe mache. Die Links aufzuarbeiten, die findet ihr dann in der Datei, in den Lyrics und natürlich auch auf der begleitenden Webseite. Die findet sich wie immer unter chaosradio.ccc.de und Feedback ist gerne gesehen unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Da könnt ihr uns einfach Kommentare schicken, Hinweise, Lob und Tadel. Ansonsten gibt es demnächst auch wieder Chaosradio. Einmal im Monat wie gehabt und auch bei Chaosradio International und den englischen Ausgaben sind in letzter Zeit mal wieder ein paar neue Sendungen dazugekommen. Wer da noch nicht reingehört hat, möchte das vielleicht mal versuchen. Wo ich eh gerade schon dabei bin, hier den Roundup der Eigenwerbung zu betreiben, Chaos TV, unser bunte Tüte-Podcast hat in letzter Zeit eine ganze Menge Zulauf bekommen. Interessante Dokumentationen. Wir sind da auch immer wieder für Neues aufgeschlossen. Wenn ihr also Tipps habt für Content, der dort erscheinen sollte, das hören wir mal gerne. Ja, insofern, ich bedanke mich bei dir, Maha. Für den aufschlussreichen Einblick in die Welt der Sprachen und dann bleibt uns nur noch Tschüss zu sagen. Und ein Gruß geht an die Hörer und bis bald.